bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans
parlement hebdo 45 minutes d'actualité
politique et parlementaire bonjour ni t
elle au point et c'est une semaine
marquée par l'annoncé surprise de jean
marc ayrault le premier ministre veut
remettre à plat la fiscalité en
fusionnant par exemple l'impôt sur le
revenu et la csg
il consultera les parlementaires et les
partenaires sociaux dans les prochains
jours les maires de france réunis pour
leur congrès annuel colère fiscale gong
sur les rythmes scolaires inquiétudes
sur les finances des collectivités
locales jean marc ayrault aussi voulu
rassurant mais les élus ont le blues
à quatre mois des élections municipales
et puis le plus de l'hebdo avec un
nouveau thriller politique 1974 mort de
georges pompidou valéry giscard
d'estaing nomme jacques chirac premier
ministre très vite les relations entre
les deux hommes se compliquent entraîne
admiration et incompréhension la rupture
c'est le titre de ce téléfilm diffusé
sur france 3 et pour développer toute
cette actualité bonjour henri guaino
bonjour je rappelle ancien conseiller
spécial de nicolas sarkozy député ump
des yvelines
vous connaissez la tradition on va
écouter ce que les parlementaires
pensent de vous et puis bien sûr on
réagira à tout ça juste après écoute et
en médiane aubin
la république la france est le gaullisme
plume républicain actifs je pense qu'ils
cherchent à comprendre l'avenir de la
france mais on s'arrêtant dans le passé
je pense qu'il a une bonne connaissance
de l'histoire et il faudrait davantage
s'appuyer sur cette réalité de
l'histoire pour se projeter dans
l'avenir
une pensée une volonté de la volonté une
forme de courage aussi
henri guaino c'est quelqu'un de
déterminé quelqu'un d'un peu atypique et
quelqu'un aussi que sympathique quand on
le connaît davantage parce qu'il a il
il a besoin d'être mieux connue je pense
que des éloges aureliano presque en tout
cas c'est plutôt gentils vous remercie
mes collègues d'être aussi indulgent mon
égard on a beaucoup travaillé et je
voudrais savoir si vous êtes ambitieux
aussi
oui bien sûr oui j'ai toujours été
ambitieux mais aussi en nous si on n'est
pas ambitieux fait pas de politique la
politique c'est quoi sinon l'ambition de
peser sur l'histoire de changer le monde
de changer la société
je peux aussi à titre personnel il sort
ça va me faire de la politique c'est
l'ambition incarner ckoi prochaine
ambition 2015 et régionales pour
l'instant je n'ai pas de vos prêtres
cette ambition top ce nombre tombe sur
une autre fille et qui sort de je ne
sais où dans un journal dans le parisien
j'ai donc france je démens pour
l'instant avoir aucun objectif électoral
dans les mois et les années à venir mais
nous verrons ce seront les circonstances
soient à présent c'est une question que
je ne me pose pas mais aussi le mont
plume qui revient vous aimez écrire
guaino j'écris dans la douleur mais je
pense qu'on ne peut pas préciser une
pensée on ne peut pas donner une forme à
une pensée en tout cas moi si si on
n'écrit pas alors on parlait tout à
l'heure mais d'abord on va revoir les
temps forts de la semaine et retour
d'abord sur un mauvais anniversaire pour
l'ump
18 novembre 2012 un séisme politique
frappait le premier parti d'opposition
de france à l'issue d'un scrutin serré
et sur fond de soupçons jean françois
copé s'autoproclamer président de l'ump
sous les yeux médusés de françois fillon
aujourd'hui le parti cherche toujours
son chef et sa voix les civils la
première bougie vient d'être soufflée il
force est de constater que l'ump de jean
françois copé balbutie encore alors que
le gouvernement est au plus bas dans
l'opinion
l'opposition peine à en profiter selon
un sondage ifop paru hier
74% des français estiment que l'ump
ferait moins bien ou ni mieux ni moins
bien que l'actuel exécutif socialiste
la guerre des chefs a laissé le parti en
crise la situation n'est pas idéale
loin de là mais c'est une situation qui
permet de travailler de se préparer pour
les élections municipales notamment de
préparer un projet d'avoir une vraie
direction aucun véritable gagnant de
cette guerre jean-françois copé est jugé
par les français comme arrogant et
arriviste selon un autre sondage
de son côté françois fillon peine à
exister médiatiquement et commet des
maladresses de communication je pense
que françois fillon n'a pas envie d'être
systématiquement sur les médias et ce
n'est pas son rôle je crois qu'encore
une fois ce qu'il faut c'est que l'on
travaille que l'on propose que l'on que
l'on réfléchisse et condamne une
alternative avec les partis centristes
qui se réunifie est à front national qui
marquent des points 8 p pourrait ne plus
être le centre de gravité de la droite
le grand débat de fond c'est le choix
entre la lepénisation croissante des
idées de l'ump ligne tous nés par jean
françois copé ou la ligne aux listes de
rassemblement par dessus le clivage des
coteries face à la crise et pour sauver
le pays face à ce que fait la gauche
les élections municipales en 2014 seront
le prochain curseur pour savoir si oui
ou non
l'ump toujours le premier parti
d'opposition alors henri guaino un an
après les difficultés sont toujours là y
at il encore quelqu'un pour diriger et
aussi un carnet l'ump alors dirigé oui
l'ump elle est présidée par
jean-françois copé
tout le monde a accepté
résultat des élections de l'année
dernière donc on a un président on n'a
toujours pas renouvelé les autres
instances je pense qu'il va falloir le
faire après
après les municipales sa course quand
même un petit problème de fonctionnement
quotidien et de légitimité de ses
instances et des français interrogés ce
n'est pas si clair le sondage note le
président à l'ump ça veut pas dire que
l'ump aujourd'hui soit un carnet ça veut
pas dire qu'elle ait trouvé un
fédérateur
ça veut pas dire qu'elle soit audible
compréhensible mais souvenez-vous de
détails dans quel était le parti
socialiste un an et demi après des
élections de 2007
souvenez-vous de madame royal menaçant
d'entraîner madame aubry devant des
tribunaux jeu des salaires un parti qui
a subi des échecs électoraux de cette
nature qui ne demandent plus confrontés
à la crise économique sociale que nous
traversons qui oblige à une remise en
cause de toutes les idées anciennes et
forcément traverse une période de deux
crises et de remises en cause pour lui
même le temps vu les échéances qui sont
à ma s'est rapproché de cette remise à
blâmer c'est une réalité c'est tout ça
ne sert à rien de se poser la question
de savoir si elle a le temps aujourd'hui
le quai ce qu'est ce que constatent les
français mais qu'est ce que constate
d'ailleurs les militants de lmp les élus
c'est que le départ nicolas sarkozy a
laissé un vide profond ce vide n'est pas
n'est pas remplie personnes à lui tout
seul ne peut remplir ce vide et en plus
c'est une l'ump est un parti qui est
composé de plusieurs familles politiques
de sensibilités très différentes ancrée
dans l'histoire et a besoin d'un
fédérateur
c'est d'ailleurs la logique de la vème
république aurait gain de deux petites
questions rapidement aussi sur sur l'ump
seriez vous prêt à gouverner dès demain
matin c'est cécile ne fallait ma
conviction est que
s'il fallait gouverner bien gouverner
mais que nous sommes nous ne sommes pas
prêts aujourd'hui nous n'avons pas
achevé notre reconstruction ni politique
ni intellectuel ni morale pour être sûr
d'affronter le mieux possible c'est la
crise actuelle je le dis très à la fois
avec avec un peu de avec un peu triste
mais beaucoup de réalisme il faut que
nous en soyons conscients et d'ailleurs
je pense qu'il serait absurde que les
échéances pas du tout bon pour le pays
non plus que les élections se soient
bousculés par quoi commencer ça je pense
que la dissolution serait dans l'état
actuel des choses une manoeuvre et que
la vidéo qui pour vous mais pour tout le
monde parce que d'abord personne ne sait
si l'assemblée qui sortirait de cette
dissolution three gouvernable imaginez
que dans les circonstances actuelles le
front national entre massivement ou en
tout cas suffisamment pour faire la
bascule entre la droite et la gauche
vous imaginez ce que serait le ce que
serait cette assemblée ce que serait
donc le le gouvernement de la france
c'est la france aura encore plus de mal
à être gouvernés il a la majorité
actuelle a reçu un mandat
il faut qu'elle n'exerce et nous
présente la public de premier ministre
il faut qu'il prenne bien conscience de
la gravité de la situation et qui change
le plus rapidement possible de cap et
politique voilà la vérité maintenant
après personne n'est maître des
circonstances et c'est au président de
l'apic à prendre ses responsabilités la
dissolution par exemple où le référendum
n'appartiennent qu'à lui ce sont des
décisions qui lui appartient de prendre
ou de ne pas prendre je n'y suis pas
favorable
on va passer au bar dit henri guaino si
vous le voulez bien jean-marc ayrault on
veut remettre à plat la fiscalité
et jean marc ayrault a donc pris tout le
monde de court en annonçant une grande
réforme fiscale annonce faite au moment
même où le budget 2014 était adoptée à
l'assemblée 320 voix pour 242 contre
cette fois aucune voix de la gauche n'a
manqué le grand soir fiscal promis par
jean marc ayrault pourrait s'appliquer
dès la prochaine loi de finances
yoann là à la sortie du conseil des
ministres
la fiscalité n'était clairement pas le
sujet le plus porteur du moment avant la
victoire qu'est ce qu'on leur a mis sur
le dos la victoire est toujours possible
la ministre de l'économie en tête la
sélection gouvernementales avaient
choisi de filer la métaphore
footballistique
c'est une leçon aussi pessimiste ceux
qui pensent que c'était foutu
alors les mêmes qui la veille disait
banque de france les bulles sur le
terrain fiscal
pas question de dévoiler son plan de jeu
le match commence à peine
les ministres en quelques mots c'est en
zone mixte pourtant l'information est
aussitôt confirmée par la porte-parole
du gouvernement la remise à plat de la
fiscalité a bien fait partie des débats
et sur le sujet le sélectionneur
hollande a félicité le capitaine héros
pour son action offensive
le président de la république a qualifié
cette initiative de très utiles
ces discussions qui ont pour ambition au
fond de remettre davantage de lisibilité
d'efficacité de justice dans notre
système fiscal
prudence car les premiers arbitres de la
réforme seront les partenaires sociaux
la rencontre se jouera à domicile à
matignon lundi et mardi prochains tout
sera sur la table a promis le premier
ministre
l'équipe adverse a du mal à y croire
c'est pas parce qu'on prend de mauvaises
décisions à un moment donné qu'on doit
tout d'un coup changer de pied pour
appeler un vaste débat c'est pas le
sujet sujet c'est quelle politique
économique et sociale cohérente et
stable pour la france
là dessus on attend toujours une réponse
moi ce que je crains c'est que cette
grande réforme fiscale
elle annonce une augmentation
généralisée des impôts et ça les
français n'en veulent plus ils n'en
peuvent sur le dossier jean marc ayrault
a pour l'instant réussi le sans-faute
satisfaire tous les supporters de sa
majorité mais sur les impôts
le premier ministre s'apprête à jouer le
match de barrage le plus décisif de sa
carrière un match dont dépendra comme
pour didier deschamps la reconduction de
son contrat alors cette réforme fiscale
le coût politique de la semaine on en
parle tout de suite dans le zou
on en parle avec jean daniel levy
bonjour jean daniel directeur de
l'opinion pour l'institut harris
interactive
est ce que pour vous c'est le coût
politique de la semaine
ou est ce que c'est une réelle avancée
pour les français d'une manière générale
on peut rappeler que c'est la première
préoccupation des français aujourd'hui
est parmi l'un des premiers sujets de
conversation des français
c'est une thématique était quasiment
absente au début de l'été on peut le
rappeler où le français parlé très peu d
impôts et les monter fortement en
puissance avec la perception et
d'ailleurs on voit bien dans le solage
qu'on a réalisé pour la chaîne
parlementaire que les français
considèrent que le système
aujourd'hui tel qu'il fonctionne
apparaît comme étant injuste il apparaît
comme étant injuste aux yeux des
français il apparaît comme étant injuste
auprès des sympathisants socialistes il
apparaît comme étant injuste parce que
par rapport à la promesse de françois
hollande il ya une perception que ça
touche plus les classes moyennes que les
catégories supérieures mais faut-il pour
autant confiance à jean marc ayrault
pour mener cette grande réforme fiscale
en un il trouve que c'est une bonne idée
que jean marc ayrault l'amène de il faut
pas forcément confiance en tant que tel
pour pouvoir parvenir à faire en sorte
qu'elles plus de justice pas plus
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui à jean marc
ayrault cas aucun des acteurs dans la
vie politique
peut-être mis à part les organisations
syndicales qui tire entre guillemets un
tout petit peu leur épingle du jeu dans
ce contexte l origine de cette réforme
fiscale une façon de reprendre la main
un petit peu sur sur le contexte actuel
où vraies avancées comme le dit jean
daniel lévy pour les aviser le mot juste
pour l'instant c'est un coup politique
et donc gouverne pas un pays en crise
avec des coups politiques car enfin
depuis que la majorité là on ne cesse de
rendre plus compliqué plus
incompréhensible le système fiscal puis
tout d'un coup on découvre que il faut
il faut que tout ça se change alors la
réforme annoncée ces corps une remise à
plat c'est pas une réforme ne sais pas
y'a pas il n'y a pas de philosophie il
ya pas du direction non il ya rien on
dit
le premier set extraordinaire il dit je
vais faire venir tous les partenaires
sociaux ils vont faire des propositions
puis on fera le tri là dedans et on
verra at il dit pas voilà voilà la
politique que je souhaite on va en
discuter
non il y emploie une expression triviale
il se mouille pas du tout bon alors il
dit ce sont faux ils disent qu'il a dit
sur le marché du travail s'il affecte le
marché du travail
les partenaires sociaux vont vont faire
la réforme c'est quand même
extraordinaire parce que
on est dans un moment sommes dans un
moment pardon ou là les corps
intermédiaires quels qu'ils soient sont
discrédités aux yeux des français c'est
les partis politiques les syndicats les
partenaires sociaux les religions
l'heure on leur remet les clefs sur sur
le sujet qui est un sujet beaucoup
éminemment éminemment politique encore
plus que le droit du travail
ce conte c'est justement jean daniel
lévy comment expliquer cette manque de
confiance à l'égard de tous les tous les
partis mais pas les noms trouve
l'essentiel 20 des éléments qui
reviennent dès 1981 quasiment où la
perception que les responsables
politiques n'arrivent pas forcément
atteindre la promesse elle utilisait
d'effectuer au cours des différentes
campagnes électorales
il est dans un contexte où aujourd'hui
il ya la perception que le politique
n'arrive pas forcément être efficace
n'est que lorsqu'il doit mener à son
action en faveur de la réduction du
chômage en faveur de la réduction des
inégalités en faveur pouvoir
potentiellement du maintien ou de la
sauvegarde du système social auquel les
français sont quand même globalement
attaché ça ne marche pas véritablement
donc ça c'est le premier aspect et puis
deuxième aspect ya également la
perception que lorsque les responsables
politiques posent aujourd'hui des seins
je parle du quotidien des français
il parle de ce pays qui ne correspond
pas véritablement au vécu des français
dans leur quotidien nokia déjà également
une attente qui est une attente de
capacité à pouvoir décrire le réel
décrire une situation qui est vécu par
l'expérience c'est le cas de leur
quotidien dans faire pour retrouver pour
être aux abonnés la première première
règle pour que les gens écoutent ce que
les potées courte à dire c'est que les
politiques reconnaissent les souffrances
des gens leurs difficultés leurs peines
voilà vous souvenez 195,1 candidats
s'étaient présentés en disant nous avons
bien travaillé ça va mieux
les gens avaient répondu à battre pour
eux et pour lui ça va et puis un autre
disait l'autre c'était deux candidats
dits de la fracture sociale à l'époque
je sais que je sais que vous allez met
déjà les français commencent à vous
écouter quand on prenait en compte la
halle à leurs malades deuxièmement c'est
pourquoi toute la classe politique qui a
été au pouvoir anc et c'est à dire qui
s'est succédé au pouvoir depuis une
trentaine d'années est à ce point
disqualifié mais tout simplement parce
que l'état de la société l'état du monde
et dramatique donc on n'en rend
forcément responsables ceux qui ont
gouverné
même si tout le monde a sa part de
responsabilité les français les français
aussi mais il ya une incapacité aux yeux
des français de la classe politique à
répondre à la crise et à répondre aux
souffrances et difficultés des gens
sujet merci beaucoup
jean daniel lévy d'être intervenu pour
cet éclairage mardi donc le premier
ministre et devant les maires de france
face à face qui promettait d'être tendue
tant il y a deux problèmes avec les
maires notamment sur la fiscalité
de nombreux mécontentements aussi sur
les restrictions budgétaires et que dire
des rythmes scolaires
le tout expliquer par fabrice qu'une et
jean marc ayrault se savait attendu mais
à son arrivée au congrès des maires de
france pas de bronca et peu de sifflet
le premier d'entre eux avaient pourtant
planté le décor tva rythmes scolaires
décentralisation les maires sont
inquiets alors à la tribune jean marc
ayrault tente de rassurer le
gouvernement est toujours prêt au
dialogue
l'immobilisme c'est le déclin et les
maires sont sans doute en première ligne
pour comprendre ce besoin des français
d'évoluer de s'adapter sans perdre nos
valeurs
oui les communes devront faire un effort
mais le gouvernement promet un
accompagnement de la souplesse de la
compréhension un discours souvent jugés
insuffisants ben je dirais paroles
paroles
c'est un peu ça me passe comme ça ce à
quoi on s'attendait j'aurais voulu qu'il
annonce des choses concrètes sur la
sueur
la réforme scolaire sur les normes les
difficultés que rencontrent les communes
aujourd'hui là dessus non façon 11000
maires réunis en congrès la marge de
manoeuvre de jean marc ayrault était
réduite dans un contexte économique
tendu
le premier ministre a surtout joué sur
la corde sensible
mais le gouvernement le sait de la
bretagne à la corse
cette corde et fragile voilà de la
bretagne à la corse la colère gronde
paroles paroles pas d'annoncés concrètes
visible en les élus n'ont pas été
convaincus et en même temps est ce que
dans le contexte actuel l'état a encore
quelque chose à promettre notamment
financièrement aux collectivités locales
d'abord voyez pourquoi la classe
politique est disqualifié c'est parce
qu'elle parle pour rien dire trop trop
souvent donc c'est votre premier
ministre de métro de disco pour ne rien
dire on peut faire des discours pour
dire quelque chose il me semble que
c'est la plupart des responsables
politiques pas tout c'est dedans mais
par des responsables politiques il n'y a
pas une prise de conscience suffisante
de la gravité de la situation dans
laquelle nous nous trouvons mais moi je
sais pas on va pas refaire larmes de
minutes un discours à garder la ligne
je suis je je pense qu'il faut il faut
que le politique apprennent et c'est
compliqué à remettre aller chercher les
causes des mots qui nous qui nous
assaillent quand l'élu vous avez
interrogé dit par exemple les normes
mais les normes c'est pas ça ne va pas
s'arranger simplement parce qu'on va
décider de faire une loi de
simplification
il faut essayer de comprendre d'où ça
vient ce qui se passe avec ce qui se
passe avec l'europe ce qui se passe avec
le renoncement politique qui consiste à
tout laisser à la bureaucratie a tout
laissé oui mais c'est une tension des
remises en cause très profonde très
profonde
pourquoi c'est un discours de
transgression et de remise en cause de
tout ce qui nous a conduits à la société
et au monde dans lequel nous vivons qui
est invivable
voilà un jeu wii bien sûr les horizons
sans raison pour plusieurs raisons
d'abord parce que on en fait la variable
d'ajustement de toutes les politiques
d'austérité de tout petit ajustement
c'est pas supportable il ya une
insécurité maintenant qui est qui et qui
est très grand deane savent plus selon
quelles règles sont gouvernés puis un
jour on leur annonce les les
scolaire le lendemain au change de leurs
fiscalités leur dotation
ça c'est la première sur de la deuxième
c'est que leur statut est devenu un
statut insupportable de précarité de
deux matériellement et moralement il est
insupportable en plus ils sont assaillis
par les juges parce que c'est pas leurs
parents l'état ne s'est pas leur parler
c'est pas que l'état ne s'est pas
seulement leur parler c'est que l'état
aujourd'hui d'avoir perdu son envol
c'est la france la france est un pays
qui sait qu qui a été construite par
l'état
la société a été confondu par l'état
juste si l'état comme c'est le cas
aujourd'hui
après une dérive de 30 ou 40 ans sa
baisse autant à une autorité une
légitimité aussi contesté quelques
années aujourd'hui c'est tous des faits
et on voit la france se défaire vous
parliez tout à l'heure des provinces
enfin on voit revenir des régionalismes
les danses qu'ils ont de pire on voit
les communautés les quartiers les
territoires les classes sociales
t la france est en train de voir
ressurgir toutes les fractures
toutes les divisions contre lesquels
elle s'est construite
c'est donc ex amant g ou et la prise en
compte la prise de conscience de la
gravité de cette situation et où est-ce
qu'on en tire les conséquences dans le
discours par exemple le héros devant les
maires ou dans le discours du président
de la république et de vous parler des
statuts et c'est très important le
statut de l'élu d'ailleurs mercredi
l'assemblée nationale s'est penché sur
le statut des cumulards il l'avait
promis il a obtenu la fin du cumul des
mandats manuel valls a tenu parole et
fait respecter la promesse de françois
hollande
puisque les députés ont fini par voter
la mesure le texte avait été totalement
modifié par les sénateurs qui s'était
exclu du dispositif
retour sur ce texte avec germain andrieu
c'était l'une des soixante promesses de
françois hollande est un avertissement
clair de manuel valls à la tribune le
projet de loi sur le non-cumul des
mandats doit être adoptée à l'assemblée
et sans aucune exception pour les
sénateurs il n'y a pas de surprise il
n'y aura pas de surprise
cette loi oui conformément à
l'engagement de président la public
devra s'appliquer à tout le monde en
même temps et dans les mêmes conditions
n'y en a pas de surprise parce que
chacun aura le temps de se préparer de
prendre cette décision
chaque élu en situation de cumul
aura donc la possibilité de préparer
sereinement cette échéance et conservera
sa liberté de choix en pouvant aller au
terme de chacun de ses mandats actuels
autrement dit pas question de valider le
camouflet des sénateurs en septembre
dernier 25 sénateurs socialistes avaient
voté avec l'opposition et le parti
radical de gauche pour vider le projet
de loi de sa substance une position
inacceptable pour le gouvernement la
position adoptée par le sénat en
première lecture et est inconciliable
avec le texte très largement adoptée par
l'assemblée nationale en première
lecture le 9 juillet dernier
tout en approuvant le principe de
l'interdiction du cumul avec les
fonctions exécutives locales pour les
députés et pour les députés européens
les sénateurs ont choisi de s'exclure du
champ d'application de la réforme
l'assemblée nationale ayant le dernier
mot les députés ont sans surprise
valider définitivement la première
version du texte examiné
elle interdit aux sénateurs le cumul des
mandats alors on règle nos lors de la
discussion à l'assemblée il y avait très
peu d'élus ump présent la droite a un
peu joué à un fantômas visiblement les
élus avaient la tête ailleurs peut-être
déjà aux municipales est ce que ce n'est
pas une démonstration par l'absurde de
l'utilité de l'interdiction du cumul des
mandats
non non je ça n'a rien à voir simplement
à l'assemblée nationale et vous savez
très bien la majorité n'accepte jamais
aucun amendement surtout sur une réforme
de principe le trouble comme celle ci
voilà donc il n'y a pas de discussions
en vérité moi je suis totalement opposé
à ce genre de loi est ce genre
d'interdiction d'ailleurs j'espère que
l'opposition mettra son programme
d'alternance l'abrogation de cette loi
voilà en tout cas c'est ma position
parce que c'est aux électeurs de décider
il faut arrêter une bonne fois pour
toutes de décider à leur place si les
électeurs considèrent que quelqu'un fait
bien plus pour remplit bien plusieurs
mandats pourquoi pourquoi 2 pourquoi 3 à
partir de il ya des gens qui sont
capables de faire quatre mandats très
très grave quatre mandats très bien et
d'autres incapables d'en remplir un bon
c'est mais c'est aux électeurs de
décider donc
ces pouvoirs voulaient abroger je sais
pas ce que vous décideront mes amis ce
que décidera l'opposition d'ici là moi à
titre personnel je suis pour
l'abrogation de cette loi je suis
d'ailleurs pour l'abrogation de toutes
les règles qui empêchent les électeurs
de décider de choisir ce qu'ils ont
envie de choisir voilà je vais je aller
autolog de l'assemblée nationale propose
de réduire de 40% la dignité des
éventuels cumuls à ce que vous en pensez
mais je vous dis juste quand on aura
fait une assemblée uniquement de
professionnels qui ne seront plus
enraciné nulle part je pense qu'on
n'aura pas fait faire un grand progrès
la république
quant à la cantadissa de la déontologie
là aussi ça suffit arrêtons jeu arrêtons
non les députés non les parlementaires
non les élus les maires non plus n'ont
pas n'ont pas ne jouissent pas de
privilèges exorbitants la plupart font
des sacrifices considérables pour
remplir ses mandats la plupart ont
abandonné la moitié voire les deux tiers
voire parfois plus de 2 de leurs revenus
pour pouvoir siéger à l'assemblée
nationale
bon pour pouvoir servir leurs
concitoyens donc moi madame le noir je
je je lui adresserait une remarque et
dense est dans cette surenchère je vous
lirai voilà madame combien gagnez-vous
par mois
quels sont vos revenus je souhaite que
les revenus du déontologue soit rendue
publique
bon je souhaite que l'on dise audi
antolin que pendant que des oncologues
de l'assemblée nationale elle ne pourra
pas gagner plus que l'indemnité
parlementaire de base et deuxièmement
qu'elle ne pourra pas exercer d'autres
activités
nous verrons si madame lenoir trouve que
c'est juste non mais il ya un moment ça
suffit il faut que chacun se dise
est ce que j'aimerais me voir appliquer
le traitement que je réserve aux autres
voilà ça c'est comme l'histoire de la
publicité des patrimoines qui finalement
a été a été limité est ce que tous les
français
est ce que tous les français veulent
afficher leur patrimoine sur les murs la
réponse est non
donc arrêtons arrêtons de de faire des
lois de suspicion contre la classe
politique
critiquons là pour ne pas avoir réussi à
juguler la crise critiquons là parce
qu'elle ne fait pas assez bien son
travail qui ne tient pas ses promesses
mais mais arrêtons ces espèces de loi
des suspects qui dégrade la politique
qui ne fait que le jeu d
ce trend voilà henri guaino de retour
aussi à l'assemblée le projet de loi sur
les retraites il avait été lui aussi
rejeté par les sénateurs le texte
examiné en seconde lecture est donc
quasiment identique à celui adopté le 15
octobre par les mêmes députés mais le
gouvernement a été contraint d'imposer
un vote bloqué notamment sur la question
sensible de la revalorisation des
pensions alors henri guaino l'ump combat
ce projet de loi tout comme le front de
gauche pour des raisons différentes
est-ce que vous combattez le fond de la
réforme ou avant tout la méthode
alors d'abord sur l'histoire de la larve
alsacien faute il faut dire ce dont il
s'agit il s'agit de décalé de six mois
l'indexation des pensions donc de faire
perdre six mois d'indexation aux
retraités voilà moi je me suis toujours
refusé
inspirées d'anciennes nicolas sarkozy
allait proposer justement non non non on
n'a jamais vous ne dites pas à 100 mais
n'a jamais voulu toucher aux pensions
il n'a jamais accepté la désindexation
des pensions alors là elles sont pas
complètement des index et même un père
six mois on décale de six mois ce qui
n'est ce qui n'est pas rien moi toute
réforme des retraites qui touche au
montant des retraites et au pouvoir
d'achat des retraités est pour moi une
réforme qu'il faut absolument exclure
alors qu'est ce qu'on va vous proposer à
la place alternative à l'or il yad'abord
d'abord le l'allongement de la durée de
cotisation et et est normale elle doit
l'être pour tout le monde et
probablement n'échapperont nous pas à un
recul de l'âge de la de départ en
retraite même si il a des conséquences
un peu injuste sur une certaine partie
de la population mais il faut bien
comprendre que la solution de problèmes
des retraites comme celle de l'assurance
maladie comme celle de la sécurité
sociale en général comme celles de tous
nos comptes publics ne tient pas
simplement dans la réforme pas seulement
dans la forme des retraites ou de
l'assurance maladie
c'est un problème macroéconomiques c'est
un problème de politique économique tant
que vous aurez des millions de chômeurs
bon tant que vous aurez des millions
d'exclus tant que la société l'économie
seront dans cet état vous ne pourrez pas
avoir des comptes ni sociaux ni des
comptes publics en ordre voilà le
problème est qu'il ya aujourd'hui un
nombre de plus en plus réduits de gens
qui travaillent pour entretenir un
nombre de plus en plus grand de gens qui
ne travaillent pas pour des bonnes ou de
mauvaises raisons
il ya des chômeurs qui n'y sont pour
rien il ya les gens qui font des études
des jeunes qui font des études plus
longues il ya l'allongement de la durée
de cotisation il faut une politique
globale qui permette d'élargir
l'assiette du travail ce qui monte plus
de gens qui travaillent c'est vrai qu'il
avance est un petit peu pour en essayer
de faire tous les sujets de la semaine
quand même vous aimez le foot de haut
oui je me le foot alors qu'on ne peut
pas passer sous silence comme la
qualification des bleus pour le mondial
de 2014 au brésil
sakho n'était pas très nombreux à y
croire c'est vrai et aussi tous les
politiques ont décidé de de parler après
cette victoire
récupération ou pas et notamment celle
de françois hollande écoutez et regardez
ce reportage
la france a décroché son ticket pour le
mondial au brésil tandis qu'au même
moment dans l'hémicycle on s'affronte
autour de la réforme des retraites
messieurs s'asseyent restera dans
l'histoire passée pendant votre
intervention que la france s'est
qualifiée de là je vous demande une
suspension de séance de cinq minutes
pour réunir l'ensemble des groupes de
l'assemblée nationale pour un moment
d'unité nationale merci écoutez ces
moments sont suffisamment rare pour que
nous les bien évidemment dans les
acceptions et la séance est suspendue
pour cinq minutes mais dans l'arène
politique cette union nationale n'aura
duré qu'un soir car la lecture de cette
victoire n'est pas la même entre la
gauche et la droite
du côté de la majorité on capitalise sur
cette bonne nouvelle un peu inespéré
quand ça marche ça allait on prend en ce
moment tout ce qui est bon à prendre en
engrangeant à droite par contre tout est
bon à prendre pour comparer le succès de
l'équipe de france aux déboires du
gouvernement
une équipe comme ça oui elle peut gagner
on n'a pas l'impression que le
gouvernement puisque c'est à lui vous
faites allusion
soit en train de se remettre en cause
vis-à-vis de ses erreurs et nous
préparer à gagner mais aux quatre
colonnes cet après midi certains députés
n'ont pas pu s'empêcher de s'afficher
avec quelques accessoires
footballistique à la suite de paris
visiblement philippe gosselin fait
partie des perdants
une chance qu'on n'ait pas dit qu'on
venait en caleçon
elles viennent effectivement du principe
c'est mon garçon qui aime les arts les
métaphores entre le monde du football et
celui de la politique était donc partout
mais c'est bien françois hollande qui a
lancé le mouvement à l'issue du match
aujourd'hui
son entraîneur ses entraîneurs sa crosse
l'entraîneur ça compte
difficile de ne pas en faire un
parallèle politique pour remporter la
victoire didier deschamps a remanié son
équipe alors aux quatre colonnes on se
demande également s'il n'est pas temps
de faire des remplacements au sein du
gouvernement
est ce que ça sera un remaniement un
changement de premier ministre ne sait
pas on aura la surprise je pense d'ici
les élections municipales au mois de
mars
quand je souris henri guaino parce que
de métaphore même françois hollande que
ce soit les députés également salle des
quatre colonnes
est-ce qu'il faut seulement une victoire
en football pour pouvoir parler de bonne
nouvelle politique et c'est pas une
bonne nouvelle politique c'est une bonne
nouvelle sportive alors que ça vienne
améliorer un peu le moral très bas de la
vaccination c'est très bien moi je me
réjouis quand la france gagne quel que
soit le terrain sur lequel elle gagne
mais je suis pas un adepte non plus de
la métaphore footballistique pas plus
d'ailleurs que de la métaphore guerrière
en politique je pense la politique c'est
la politique
donc c'est pas ça qui ça ne se crée pas
des emplois ça ne ne ça ne permet pas
d'aller la justice sociale et sa couleur
français qui ont chanté la marseillaise
à tue tête ça vous a plu
ça me plait simple est toujours content
quand on chante la marseillaise avec
dans la ferveur la joie le partage c'est
quand même symbolique tout ça est ce que
c'est un peu le retour du rêve français
ou c'est pas du tout ça et nous verrons
comment ça s'est un peu c'est à dire
c'est un peu oui c'est un peu prématuré
c'est encore peu tout de même
mais quand tout le monde chante la
marseillaise et et jettent un drapeau
français moi j'en suis j'en suis très
heureux j'aimerais que ça soit le cas
dans beaucoup de domaines voilà en
économie en matière culturelle mais
aussi de s'en passer un petit message
politique aussi alors on va passer au
jeudi avec le blocus aux portes de paris
un mort et six blessés en marge des
manifestants des manifestation des
céréaliers le ministre des transports a
demandé une levée immédiate des barrages
le mouvement était organisée à l'appel
de la fédération des exploitants
agricoles d'ile-de-france objet de la
colère notamment la redistribution des
aides de la politique agricole commune
écouter ces réactions de céréales il
s'efface au blocage de stéphane le foll
notre décevant ministre on bloque les
routes donc on adopte la même position
que lui par rapport à aux décisions
qu'il s'apprête à prendre sur la réforme
de la politique agricole commune et en
plus il ya un rabot a ras-le-bol fiscale
qui concerne nos exploitations mais
aussi tous nos concitoyens on est en
train de se dire que de toute façon on
n'arrivera pas à joindre les deux bouts
moins d'être compensatoire des prix qui
commence à s'effriter
il est clair qu'aujourd'hui les
échéances qu'on a qu'on va avoir en fin
d'année on n'arrivera pas à les payer
alors ont-ils raison d'être en colère et
ce que le gouvernement actuel et le
précédent aurait dû anticiper cette
éducation à raison comme la plupart des
catégories de français
ce que je ce que je constate dans cette
affaire c'est que la question européenne
est posée voilà la question du
fonctionnement de l'europe des
directions quelques elle prend elle est
posée est allé poser pour beaucoup de
catégories presque toutes les catégories
sociales de notre pays et des autres
pays en europe d'un problème mais ça
devient un problème ça ne peut pas
continuer comme ça je dis il va falloir
la réorienter va falloir la réformer
mais on peut pas continuer de cette
façon va continuer dans cette direction
regardez ça la politique monétaire peut
pas continuer d'être ce qu'elle est on
peut pas ne pas avoir de politique
commerciale on peut pas
détruire la politique agricole commune
est rien mettra et rien mettre à la
place on peut pas appuyer avoir
politique industrielle à voir la
politique de la concurrence absolument
folle qui est celle de l'union
européenne
voilà c'est peut-être en mettre en place
toute la problématique des français il
faut peut-être remettre à plat la
fiscalité faut aussi remettre à plat la
manière dont nous construisons l'europe
est notre rapport au reste du monde et
futur et pas seulement oui c'est un
problème qui se pose sur presque tous
les dossiers de l'immigration la culture
l'économie le social autres journaux
collègue faisait remarquer que la cour
de justice s'apprêtait à rendre une
décision qui va intégrer dans l'est dans
les effectifs des entreprises les
apprentis bon ça veut dire qu'un certain
nombre d'entreprises qui dix apprentis
vont franchir des seuils donc avoir pour
avoir d'un seul coup des contraintes
supplémentaires
mais l'europe l'europe l'europe fait
passer fait passer de 7 % à 20 % le la
tva sur les centres équestres toute la
filière et qu'est ce que la saison 6
responsable via parce que l'europe c'est
très facile aussi longtemps nous
touchons pas aux noms mais l'europe
n'est pas en dehors de nous c'est notre
affaire à tous c'est le résultat de nos
choix
les choix quand ils ont été erroné
doivent être remises en cause on ne peut
pas continuer comme ça il faut il faut
changer l'orientation
il faut en changer l'organisation
hainaut sur tout autre sujet mais qui
reste totalement politique quoi faire un
petit retour en arrière on va parler des
années 70 c'est le plus de l'hebdo comme
on est bien que s'étant qu'on ne veut
pas aborder ces problèmes là tant qu'on
ne veut pas aborder
l'état de nos institutions l'état de
l'europe l'état de la mondialisation on
ne répondrons sera incapable de répondre
aux angoisses et aux souffrances des
français et donc la discrédit sur les
seuls sur la politique continuera à
grandir et nous amènera tout droit vers
les extrêmes message est passé
henri guaino je vous le promets tess et
le plus de l'hebdo
on a parlé d'un téléfilm qui sera
diffusé sur france 3 le 26 novembre
prochain un nouveau thriller politique
construit sur une période qui a marqué
la droite française est la cinquième
république des relations très
compliquées entre valéry giscard
d'estaing et jacques chirac ne tout
résumé par simon barbarie un soir
d'avril 1974 le président de la
république georges pompidou meurt
brutalement le jeune jacques chirac
considéré par les proches du défunt
comme l'héritier du gaullisme se voit
proposer le poste de premier ministre
par le nouveau président valéry giscard
d'estaing nouvelle ère vient de s'ouvrir
j'ai promis le changement français jeune
france moderne mais je ne le ferai pas
sans vous je vous demande de bien
vouloir accepter d'être mon premier
ministre le tempérament les goûts les
convictions les stratégies tout oppose
les deux hommes et les conduisent à la
rupture
après deux ans de collaboration la
rupture c'est le titre de la fiction
diffusée la semaine prochaine sur france
3 jamais dans la caricature toujours
dans l'incarnation
les scénaristes brosse un portrait
édifiant de cette période troublée pour
la droite française
les fonctions sont pas stupides s'il
faut donner une majorité alors nouveau
président qu'il a donnée mais cette
majorité je lai elle a besoin d'être
apaisé et c'est pour cela que je veux
chirac
les gaullistes historiques l'envol il
n'en sera que plus heureux d'être avec
l'appui comme d'habitude gaulliste
suivront divergence idéologique et
personnelle et omniprésence des
entourages la vie politique d'hier n'a
décidément pas pris une ride
patrice duhamel bonjour vous êtes l'un
des écrivains au delà des auteurs de
cette fiction
pourquoi d'ailleurs pas un documentaire
et pourquoi ce film ce téléfilm
alimentaire il ya eu des documentaires
sur cette période
l' avantage de la fiction politique
quand elle est basée sur des événements
réels ce qui est le cas dans dans cette
fiction c'est qu'on est au plus près des
personnalités qu'on est au plus près des
coulisses et qu'on peut traiter toute
une série de choses qu' il serait
difficile de traiter dans un
documentaire était vraiment la haine
entre les deux ah oui c'était là c'était
la haine au bout de quelques mois
j'ai bien vécu cette cette période on
est passé en quelques jours du
malentendu à l'incompréhension de la
compréhension au divorce et du divorce
allen et deux ou trois jours après la
nomination de chirac au moment de la
formation du premier gouvernement il ya
déjà des désaccords ce qui est quand
même
henri guaino doit le savoir relativement
rares ce qui est intéressant pourquoi on
a choisi ça parce que c'est un peu
fondateur de l'histoire de la droite
depuis quarante ans parce que c'est une
page d'histoire inédite nom mail est
inédite c'est la première fois depuis
cinquante-huit que un premier ministre
décide de claquer la porte lui même et
puis on a là on a des fauves politiques
à la fois les deux héros et puis les
entourages sur les personnages
romanesques et dans l'histoire continue
henri guaino aujourd'hui ce temps elle
est faite avec des hommes donc avec des
patients avec dna et des rancoeurs avec
des d amour avec des c'est sûr
pourquoi c'est le seul à avoir quitté
avoir claqué la porte ce aussi parce
qu'ils sont partis n'était pas celui du
président sinon des haines des rancoeurs
des incompréhensions il y en a eu avant
rappelez-vous pompidou et l'idée y en a
eu après pompidou de gaulle à la fin
khamsa du ca les plus de temps mais on
n'était pas dans le même même catégorie
de personnages n'ont plus ni au même
moment de l'histoire
mais rappelez-vous rocard mitterrand etc
jeudi à dd c'est très compliqué la
cohabitation toute façon premier
ministre président de la vème république
est toujours très compliquée et les
personnalités se heurtent souvent là ça
a pris dramatique parce qu'encore une
fois le premier ministre était le chef
d'un parti qui n'était pas le parti du
président est donc tout ça c'était aller
au grand jour et a provoqué une rupture
qui en général je fais de façon
beaucoup plus actif est vrai ont légué
nous que à l'elysée quand vous étiez
conseiller spécial de nicolas sarkozy
vous occupiez le bureau de valéry
giscard d'estaing occupé son bureau
c'est le seul président de la vème
qu'ils aient choisi de ne pas aller dans
ce qu'on appelle à l'elysée le bureau du
général
il travaille dans le bureau que
j'occupais mais ils recevaient quand il
avait reçues voire une personnalité
finalement alors je vais dans le bureau
du maire
alors patrice duhamel vous avez donc co
écrit le scénario central qui est de
ceux-là rupture qu'il a été diffusée
mardi 26 novembre à 20h45 sur france 3
est ce que pour vous ce type de fiction
politique écrit au plus près de la
réalité peut donner une autre vision de
la politique de même réconcilier les
français on est capable de réconcilier
je ne sais pas en tout cas ils tous
éclairés d'éclairer éclairé tri donner
une autre image incarner les personnages
leur donner de la chair montrait parce
que ça compte
henri guaino est quand même bien placé
ici pour savoir quel est le poids le mot
entourage ne l'aiment pas parce qu'il
est il est un peu réducteur des
conseillers je crois que c'est tout à
fait important mais juste pour reprendre
ce que disait henri guaino ce qui est
passionnant dans cette affaire c'est
qu'il ya eu un malentendu immédiat
peut-être lié à la la courte période
entre la mort de georges pompidou et
l'élection ils sont pas beaucoup parlé
mais giscard clairement attendait de
chirac qui soit un premier ministre sans
état d'âme appliquant ses orientations
et chirac lui il était déjà et notamment
sous l'influencé de ses conseillers
pierre juillet marie france garaud un
couple extraordinaire au sens
étymologique du terme
il était déjà il était déjà sur une
orbite présidentielle
donc ça ne pouvait pas marcher mais ils
ne savaient pas forcément mais on l'a
cieux on l'a vu au bout de quelques
joueurs marché voilà absolument à la
donc la rupture je rappelle 26 novembre
20h45 sur france 3 henri guaino vous
avez écrit ce livre
camus au panthéon
discours imaginaire au magic pas les
films qui vous l'avez vu du feu hommage
à l'écrivain français qui aurait eu 100
ans le 7 novembre 2013
hommage aussi à son engagement politique
est ce que en ces temps troublés
l'engagement le courage politique ont
encore un sens oui plus que jamais ce
que mais l'engagement de camus était un
engagement non partisan s'est engagé il
avait été prise de position politique
mais jamais n'a jamais accepté d'être
prisonnier d'autres donnent aucun parti
et où j'écris ce matin mes parents je
pense que tout le monde devrait devrait
relire camus devrait relire les
moralistes devrait redire les gens qui
posent le problème de la conscience
humaine avec autant de haltes autant
d'acuité et autant de profondeur
quelle est la grande leçon à retenir au
fonds pour les jeunes le site de camus
c'est que tapie ni aucun principe absolu
il faut toujours trouver mettre une
limite aux eaux aux principes et la
morale dans la politique comme dans la
vie n'est jamais dans la bonne
conscience
elle est toujours dans le cas de
conscience là c'est beaucoup et henri
guaino merci patrice duhamel merci
d'avoir répondu à notre invitation
catillon se retourne semaine prochaine
avec plaisir et merci à vous pour votre
fidélité
hu